alguna vez fue la oportunidad o
posibilidad para alguien
a qué me refiero con eso es si alguna
vez alguien con alguna intervención suya
tal vez con alguna algún consejo en una
palabra logró que otra persona pudiera
concretar un sueño tal vez hizo que
tomar una decisión importante en su vida
ya esté hasta ese momento no se había
animado o aún más lograron que esa
persona se pudiera superar a sí misma y
encontrarse con su verdadera identidad
bueno son muy imposibilidad para alguien
y alguien también lo fue para mí
cuando hablamos de discapacidad muchas
veces o tal vez la mayoría de las veces
los asociamos a lo negativo
a los no no puede caminar no va a lograr
hacerlo no es capaz
tal vez hasta pensamos que nunca va a
cumplir un sueño
pero déjenme decirles que la
discapacidad hay muchos
si puede lograrlo si es capaz de
superarse a sí mismo si es capaz de
conseguir y llegar a sus metas y saben
por qué
porque la fuerza que te motiva y que te
hace llegar no está en las piernas no
está en los brazos ni siquiera en la
cabeza esa fuerza está en el corazón
y yo hasta ahora no conozco a ninguna
persona que no tenga corazón
álex es un ex alumno de la escuela de
apoyo a la inclusión número 9 de
victórica
es un chico alegre
este hincha de boca
le gusta mucho o no le gusta las clases
de educación física ama el deporte llama
a competir
además álex tiene parálisis cerebral por
lo que este móvil está en silla de
ruedas
allá por el 2017 se una invitación a la
escuela para una capacitación una
jornada aquí en santa rosa donde se
proponía un deporte que sea sencilla de
ruedas motorizadas
en la directora de la escuela a este que
asista y vengo esta capacitación aquí me
encuentro con unos profes y les consultó
por un alumno que tengo que está en
silla de ruedas pero no motorizada para
ver si me proponían algún deporte porque
como mencioné antes le gusta mucho la
actividad
eso me hablaron de noche a un deporte
que es específicamente para personas con
parálisis cerebral
y en el cual así a simple explicación
consiste en un boeing blanco con seis
bocas azules y 6 reuters donde el
objetivo es que mis muchas quede lo más
cerca posible del bochín blanco
impidiendo a través de diferentes
estrategias de juego que las bochas del
contrincante queden más cerca
bueno sigo con esta propuesta en la
escuela imagínense un desafío también
para mí porque tuve que aprender el
deporte
se lo propongo álex en las clases
habituales de educación física donde
enseguida como decimos la propia
educación física
le agarró la mano
ya tuvimos un mes dos meses de práctica
y venimos a participar a los juegos
deportivos pampeanos para personas con
discapacidad
y un grupo más de alumnos de la escuela
en las disciplinas de atletismo
luego de participar al ain clasifica
para viajar al chaco representando a la
provincia de la pampa en este deporte
imagínense la alegría para él un deporte
que hacía muy poco que practicaba
pero del cual él
había emprendido junto conmigo
a realizarlo de manera casi natural era
como si de repente todo el tiempo
hubiese estado esperando o de practicar
este deporte
viajamos a charco
nos acompañó su papá marcelo y allá en
el chaco empezamos a convenir el primero
el segundo partido ambos lo ganan
y en una de estas competencias el papá
es un comentario que a mí me sacudió el
papá dijo
yo no sabía que mi hijo jugaba
para nosotros un simple comentario pero
para mí no
porque me hizo pensar
sino que lo rodean
no podemos ver o no somos capaces de
valorar y ver su potencial o lo que él
sabe hacer como podemos exigirle tal vez
a los demás
que lo vean
aquí también me doy cuenta que la
mayoría de las veces las invitaciones se
las ponemos nosotros y que muy lejos
está de ser sus límites
continuaron los partidos
álex pasa a cuartos de final semifinal y
gana la final
esta experiencia para él
fue muy importante no solo lo deportivo
sino lo personal
él se sentía en un contexto donde era
aceptado por todos donde todos
celebraban sus logros donde podía
interactuar más hablar más y es pues lo
destacó porque en la escuela a él le
gustaba mucho expresarse sin embargo
allá con la delegación comenzó a hablar
hablar un poco más ya expresar lo que
quería y lo que sentía
cuando regresamos
los recibieron en el pueblo para recibir
también el intendente
imagínense la alegría de él
ser campeón nacional de los juegos evita
sen bochas imagínense mi alegría de
poder acompañarlo de poder transitar
este camino con el don de dentro de mi
profesión yo venía con muchos
muchas estructuras muchas cosas que tuve
que romper el molde porque porque ahora
hay que proponer a él más que yo en una
clase de educación física
muchas veces también uno siente miedo de
poder
y romper este molde por el temor por el
temor a equivocarnos
y yo me quedo con la frase que dice mi
directora melina
es preferible equivocarse haciendo que
no hacer por temor a equivocarse
al es ahora
tiene nuevos desafíos
tiene nuevas metas y gracias también a
al deporte coche
volviendo a las oportunidades ya las
posibilidades
al es cuando vuelve consigue una silla
motorizada especial atrás le recomiendo
una silla motorizada él al tener acceso
de castilla
junto con su familia deciden donar su
silla antigua a maribel
maribel es una arena del chaco
fue contrincante de álex y estaba allí
con una silla prestada
imagínense poder continuar dando
posibilidades y oportunidades a alguien
más casi inconscientemente tal vez
ahora maribel tiene la silla de álex y
alec tiene su silla motorizada
luego de ser recibido en el pueblo donde
todos celebramos su alegría también
comenzó a entrenar ya participar en los
juegos de verano
donde también
integral lo que nosotros llamamos las
zonas 6 en los juegos deportivos
que es donde están los deportistas
con discapacidad y sin discapacidad
conviviendo compartiendo el mismo
espacio de juego compartiendo el lugar
donde juegan y aquí es donde yo quiero
hacer hincapié ya no tanto en la
inclusión sino más bien en la
convivencia donde todos seamos capaces
de ver son potenciales o sus capacidades
y dejando de lado
lo que muchos de nosotros a veces
prestamos atención apenas vemos y que
déjenme decirle que es lo menos
importante y es la discapacidad
ahora
[Aplausos]
pero tal vez serán posibilidad para
algún álex
que haya por ahí
[Aplausos]